[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 28 octobre bienvenue dans
le journal préparé par la rédaction de
tv 60,18 voici les titres de l'actualité
locale
après une chute drastique des activités
l'aéronautique est à la reprise depuis
cet été comment se porte le secteur dans
les yvelines où deux grands groupes et
des sous traitants sont implantées un
reportage dans l'entreprise permaswage
aux clayes-sous-bois pierre blandin
consultants en aéronautique sera
également notre invité nous prendrons
des nouvelles des cadets de la
gendarmerie toute cette semaine ils
vivent un premier stage sur le camp de
ben un avant goût de la vie militaire au
programme notamment exercice de tir et
marche de nuit immersion à leurs côtés
lors d'une journée
et puis décidément la série validé sur
la français aiment les artistes
yvelinois il y avait déjà à tiques et
bosh est désormais hardos au casting de
la saison 2 ryan et raouf deux frères
jumeaux originaire de mantes la jolie
rencontre
tout à l'heure également un supermarché
tourner vers lentilles gaspillage est
ouvert depuis quelques jours à maurepas
[Musique]
je vous le disais dans les titres après
des mois de difficultés le secteur de
l'aéronautique repart c'est le cas par
exemple à l' usine permaswage aux
clayes-sous-bois spécialisée dans la
production de pièces destinées à la
circulation des fluides dans les avions
à l'entreprise connaît une reprise
d'activité suite à la crise sanitaire le
reportage de nicolas landry les machines
tournent à plein régime les petites
pièces destinées aux avions se succèdent
et les commandes des clients se
multiplient c'est la relance de
l'activité dans l'usiné termas wage des
clayes-sous-bois après une année 2009
difficile à cause de la crise sanitaire
aujourd'hui on est encore à 20 25 % en
dessous de l'activité j'allais dire en 3
8 de l'ensemble des installations de
production qu'on a sur le site ce site
industriel du groupe américain est un
sous traitant des constructeurs d'avions
leur spécialité la fabrication de ces
pièces pour former la tuyauterie des
avions si j'ai travaillé 32 heures par
semaine il y a quelques mois stéphane
est revenu aujourd'hui à des semaines de
35 heures
voix par rapport à ce qu'on a à faire
derrière le le cadencement on voit on
voit que les panels ils sont bien
remplies et que oui ça on voit que ça
monte mais c'est pas savons pas non plus
vertigineux seconde c'est s'est
doucement mais sûrement on va dire si à
un moment la délocalisation du site
étaient envisagés il ya un peu moins
d'un an un accord social et le chômage
partiel a maintenu lusine aux
clayes-sous-bois la mise en place de ce
régime appelle des a permis de baisser
les tensions et de nous organiser de
façon à ce que ni aucune perte aucune
casse sociale dans l'entreprise avec
l'augmentation de la cadence de
production de l'a320 par airbus les
perspectives sont bonnes pour permaswage
qu'on était sur l'année 2001 à 40
appareils par mois et on passerait à
49,50 dès l'année prochaine donc une
augmentation significative fin 2022
début 2023 perma swatch prévoit de
réaliser 90 % du chiffre d'affaires
réalisé en 2010 neuf à condition de
gérer les problématiques suivantes la
gestion de l'approvisionnement la hausse
des coûts sur les matériaux de
production ou encore la montée en
compétences et pour continuer à parler
de ce sujet pierre flandin est avec moi
en visioconférence bonsoir bonsoir
consultant aéronautique vous avez exercé
dans les yvelines notamment vous avez
plus de 25 ans d'expérience dans ce
domaine et vous êtes aujourd'hui à la
tête de votre propre cabinet alors la
crise sanitaire a fait chuter
drastiquement l'activité dans le secteur
de l'aéronautique qui se reprend depuis
cet été on a vu les compagnies aériennes
avec de nouveaux le retour des passagers
airbus et boeing aussi qui parle d'une
vente de vente qui sont repartis à la
hausse la sortie de crise était prévu
pour l'année prochaine alors que les
premières prévisions parlait d'une
sortie de crise entre 2023 2025 est ce
que cette tendance de la reprise qui
s'est aperçu cet été ce qu'elle se
poursuit à l'automne
oui on peut dire que
elle est bien engagée avec je dirais des
des variations suivant le type le type
d'appareil si on se place du côté des
constructeurs aéronautiques
commerciaux je pense que la reprise est
bien est bien entamée avec de l'avancé
par rapport aux prévisions précédentes
dans le domaine des avions court
courrier ce qu'on appelle les single hey
l'a320 et le boeing 737 puisque les
court courriers ou les vols intérieurs
ont plutôt bien bien bien repris par
contre effectivement ça a plus de
difficultés à redémarrer sur les
appareils dits laurenge donc chez airbus
330 à 350 ou là effectivement le trafic
aérien n'a pas repris ce qu'il était
avant la avant la pandémie donc des
différences à à noter au sein de
l'aviation civil aviation commerciale
skis aussi des différences à noter entre
l'aviation civile l'aviation aussi
militaire est ce que la reprise est sur
la même tendance ou est ce qu'il ya des
différences justement entre ces deux
types d'aviation pour être pour être
franc nous en france mon l'aviation
militaire on sait qu'elle est
relativement limitée à airbus avec
l'a400m et surtout d'assaut avec avec le
rafale
dassault aura été finalement beaucoup
moins impactés qu'airbus part par le
biais de la pandémie
parce que le bas le militaire a continué
à continuer à fonctionner et le business
jets finalement c'est bien maintenue
puisque les je dirais les gens et dans
les moyens d'utiliser ce genre de ce
genre de transport long plus privilégiés
par rapport à l'aviation commerciale
dans le but de se protéger de la
pandémie pendant ces sept années où ces
deux ans alors dans les articles 6 qui
sortent sur sur ce domaine sur la
reprise du secteur de l'aéronautique à
certains sous traitants qui s'inquiète
d'une reprise trop forte dans un
contexte de crise dont le rappel des
matières premières aussi à cette pénurie
des composants électroniques et suez est
ce que ça peut affecter à votre avis ce
secteur de l'aéronautique
il est clair qu'il va se
il va se générer de deux problèmes comme
vous l'avez signalé effectivement lié à
la disponibilité des matières premières
que ce soit je dirai tout toute matière
notamment les les aciers les aciers
spéciaux les alliages et c'est donc ça
ça va arriver à une disponibilité il ya
déjà une tension du marché à ce niveau
là et les sous traitants utilise en
utilisant ce type de matériaux comme les
forgerons les gens qui font du moulage
des choses comme ça commence déjà à
avoir
ce genre de problématique et l'autre
problématique ça va être également un
problème de capacité en ont pas liées à
la matière première mais lié aussi à la
main d'oeuvre puisque tout le monde n'a
pas utilisé forcément les moyens que le
gouvernement a mis enfants en place pour
notamment la pld donc l'activité
partielle longue durée pour garder le
garder du personnel et donc
effectivement il va y avoir cette
problématique de recrutement et de
disponibilité de personnel pour suivre
ses remontées en cadence ça c'est pour
les prévisions le panorama ponot
panorama global sur ce secteur de
l'aéronautique si on met le curseur à
présent sur les yvelines où ce secteur
est bien présent avec des grands groupes
on peut citer safran airbus mais aussi à
des sous traitants qui sont implantées
dans le département comment se traduit
la reprise est ce que finalement le
département des yvelines et est un
moteur de cette reprise
le département oui le département des
yvelines comme vous l'avez dit accueille
un certain nombre de d'abord de grands
oem comme comme comme airbus de grands
sous traitants comme comme comme safran
et d'autre mais il est je dirais le 1
des reflets ou un reflet de ce que peut
être le marché de l'aéronautique au
niveau du territoire du territoire
national donc effectivement n'y pas plus
ou moins impactés mais de la même
manière que le lançant des acteurs du
territoire national et enfin on
terminera par là c'est un secteur aussi
en pleine innovation l'objectif c'est la
neutralité carbone dans le transport
aérien et ce en 2050 le plan france
roland justement aborde cette question
avec un soutien pour la r&d aéronautique
1,5 milliard d'euros qui seront dédiés
justement à ce volet du plan france
relance avec déjà 62 projets qui ont été
soutenus dont six dans les yvelines avec
376 millions d'euros ces innovations
c'est quoi c'est l'avion vers on entend
beaucoup parler d'avions verts justement
en ce moment dans l'actualité passer
l'avion versé d'avion décarbonée c'est
effectivement quand vous l'avez dit le
lait la viande alors l'avion électrique
peut-être pas notamment dans le domaine
du transport aérien mais en tout cas le
l'hydrogène l'hydrogène est temps avec
un grand est un grand sujet qui est sûre
qui est sur la table ou sur les tables à
dessin s'il peut dire depuis quelques
depuis quelques temps maintenant
effectivement les carburants soient les
carburants les biocarburants les
carburants plus verte soit effectivement
à plus long terme le une nouvelle de
nouvelles motorisations
permettant de effectivement d'atteindre
cet objectif d'avion d'avion décarbonée
justement vous parliez de biocarburants
dernière question il ya un travail en ce
moment qui est fait par total
injustement sur les biocarburants pour
pour l'aéronautique nous semble que
c'est avec airbus
ça fait déjà quelques années que cessent
ces biocarburants dirais qu'il ya des
allers-retours sur le sujet entre les
entre les abus des avionneurs où
l'avionneur français airbus et les
acteurs et les acteurs du domaine tout à
fait avec safran par non et non avec
airbus ce travail mais vous l'évoquez un
travail un qui date déjà de nombreuses
années merci pierre flandin d'avoir été
avec nous je vous en prie je le rappelle
vous êtes consultant aéronautique
[Musique]
dans l'actualité il avait été promu dès
janvier dernier mais c'est hier mercredi
qu'il a reçu son insigne des mains du
président de la république le maire de
poissy karl olive a été fait chevalier
de la légion d'honneur par emmanuel
macron la cérémonie se tenait ce
mercredi soir à l'elysée huit personnes
en tout ont été distingués depuis
quelques jours un nouveau supermarché a
ouvert ses portes à maurepas il est
discrète mais c'est surtout est là toute
l'originalité tourner vers lentilles
gaspillage de jeunes entrepreneurs se
sont lancés dans l'aventuré l'objectif
valoriser les produits exclus exclu de
la grande distribution céline charles et
justine brasier
c'est un super marché d'un nouveau genre
qui a ouvert ses portes samedi dernier à
maurepas packaging obsolète produits à
date courte esthétique douteuse ici pas
de gâchis ces produits destinés à la
benz ont récupéré et vendu mon cher une
démarche à deux objectifs maintenant
supermarché c'est un concept de magasins
basée sur l'anti gaspillage donc on
répond à deux objectifs principaux le
premier en fait un objectif écologique
on va s'occuper de récupérer tous les
produits écarté du circuit de grande
distribution classique et le deuxième
objectif c'est un objectif qui est
économique en fait à nous
on récupère ses produits et on les
revend entre 20 et 50% moins cher que la
grande distribution classique des prix
pouvant être divisé par deux et
l'impression de faire un geste pour
l'environnement de quoi ravir les
clients qui affluent déjà aux portes du
magasin c'est très important qu'il y
avait plus de magasins dans ce sens
parce que comme ça les produits sont pas
jetés ils sont comestibles sont propres
c'est important parce qu'ils sont les
cas par exemple elles sont bonnes elles
sont pas mal et voit la 3ds je dis ça
sans condition pour faire comme sous si
en plus parce qu'en fait on a des
produits que au lieu de j'étais enfin de
voir là qu'il faut qu'on profite parce
qu en fait des gens valables à bord
lancé par deux jeunes entrepreneurs le
magasin vise les 1200 références sur les
400 mètres carrés du magasin les
produits sont récupérées chez les
agriculteurs les usines les grossistes
ou encore les centrales logistiques les
gens en plus en plus attention à la
planète c'est tous les jours qu'on
entend parler et puis bah le pouvoir
d'achat c'est un peu aussi c'est venu
complètement le centre ce sera sur la
table donc d'accord on mêle les deux et
qu'on vous propose une offre qui lie les
deux on se dit pourquoi pas et je pense
que les gens raison 70% du magasin est
réservé à l'anti gaspillage contre 30%
de fond de rayon comme le sel ou les
pâtes un supermarché à l'équipe est
jeune et à l'ambiance décontractée qui
projette de se multiplier dans le futur
quelques nouvelles à présent de nos
cadets de la gendarmerie toute cette
année nous allons suivre ces jeunes de
17 à 21 ans qui rêve pour certains de
devenir gendarme après avoir signé leur
engagement la sorbonne c'était le 27
septembre dernier les 70 khadr ont
commencé leur stage leur première
semaine de stage sur le camp de ben vêtu
désormais de leur uniforme ils font
leurs premiers pas dans le monde
militaire nous avons pu les suivre en
compagnie de céline charles et de
patrick jacques de dixmude
l'immersion commence pour les cadets de
la gendarmerie après une matinée de
cours théoriques l'heure est enfin à la
pratique les 70 jeunes vont enfiler leur
tri un calot un véritable honneur pour
eux c'est un grand honneur de pouvoir
porter un uniforme de la sécurité
surtout de l'armée là puisque c'est
l'armée et vraiment c'est très émouvant
ils sont partis chercher leur équipement
avec leur fameux tri et leurs chaussures
noires après quoi ils se sont allés ils
sont allés s'habiller ils sont devenus
pour la plupart d'entre eux quasiment
ils sont devenus enfin militaire déjà
rien que par l'aspect de cette tenue
militaire uniforme voilà on sent quand
même qu'il ya déjà quelque chose qui se
dégage un petit supplément d'âme les
cadets vont pour la première fois
apprendre à marcher en ligne et en
rythme pas à pas il se crée une certaine
cohésion donne un à trois déboîté pour
le amant commandant bon
le déplacement militaire ce ne se fait
qu'en groupe et au pas cadencé donc
c'est de le retirer en gîte de dire que
c'est une science se fait un grand mot
mais bon faut le savoir le maîtriser ya
clairement une cohésion dans le temps le
groupe déjà on est entre guillemets un
peu obligé parce que on est là 24/24
ensemble mais franchement c'est bon
c'est des bonnes personnes qui sont là
c'est pas des personnes qui sont là pour
dire pour dénigrer et c'est donc déjà
jeu de balle je pense qu'il ya sa part
bien dans le travail d'équipé l'esprit
de corps l'esprit de cohésion et la
partie fondamentale de la réussite et du
succès de nos engagements l'après midi
ces séances de tir pour ces novices
c'est une réelle prise de conscience
c'est l'une des missions premières dans
tous les cas de de protéger la
population et on va être amené à en cas
de terrorisme et ou de malveillance on
va être amené à utiliser notre arme de
service donc donc l'entraînement
l'entraînement passe par là aussi
en
fait c'est surtout pour nous rassurer
aussi pour savoir si on n'a pas peur de
l'âme parce que vu qu'on sera sur le
terrain avec une armée si on a peur de
larmes sais c'est pas être et pour nous
mais c'est la faulx qu'il prenne
confiance que le gendarme il est armé h
24 sur le terrain c'est son outil de
travail entre guillemets mais il faut
qu'il ait une parfaite qui une maîtrise
parfaite de l'art moment
[Musique]
le soir c'est un exercice un peu
particulier qui les attendent juste
avant d'aller se coucher les jeunes sont
appelés pour une marche de 6 km en
pleine nuit on était dans la chambre on
nous a dit de descendre en connaissant
du on a pris nos affaires donc sac
bouteilles d'eau et c'est tout et pour
nous a dit qu'on allait devoir enfin que
des terroristes allaient devoir nous
trouver et nous met devant se déplacer
en tout en toute discrétion
passer sous un tunnel ramper ou encore
se cacher un entraînement qui semble
souder ses cadets qui se sent déjà un
peu en conditions réelles je vais vous
sont partis en vrai str ça
fascinant c'est juste un rythme à suivre
il faut juste écouter ce qu'il est nos
supérieurs disent c'est pas la même
qu'en marchant rythmique en marquent
donc une personne enfin quand on marche
tout seul je veux dire c'est un peu plus
compliqué vu qu'il faut que on surveille
tout le monde
en même temps il faut qu'à chaque fois
on vérifie
si tout le monde est là il faut qu'on se
compte et tout on a pu voir la cohésion
au sein du peloton donc un renforcement
une aide entre chacun et c'était un peu
compliqué dit dj physique mais ça allait
on a réussi on est tous contents la vie
à la mort
la cohésion est une valeur essentielle
c'est très simple un jour il faut partir
en intervention la cohésion fait qu'on
forme un groupe on forme un tout et en
fait chacun se connaît on connaît les
forces de chacun les faiblesses et il
faut jouer la complémentarité
garde à vous et repos le commandant
remet la traditionnelle ronde âge des
cadets de la gendarmerie de quoi
rappeler à ces jeunes pourquoi ils ont
choisi de s'engager ce stage leur donne
en fait l'avant-goût un avant goût de ce
qu'est le métier de gendarme de ce
qu'est la formation gendarmerie de
savoir que la gendarmerie ce sont des
savoirs et des savoir-faire que ce sont
des techniques d'intervention
professionnelle et lors de ses stages
ils ont une initiation en fait découvrir
qu'elles sont toutes ces techniques et
modes d'intervention des gendarmes au
quotidien de nouveaux stages dérouleront
en février en avril les commandes en
entendent bien monter encore en
puissance entre opposants des exercices
plus physique et plus tactique une
visite de la garde républicaine est
également prévue
et puis la musique connaissez-vous ardo
ce sont deux jeunes rappeurs de
mantes-la-jolie ryanair raouf son jumeau
est depuis plusieurs années il enchaîne
les singles et clips la sortie de la
saison 2 de la série validé début
octobre a été l'occasion pour eux d'une
première apparition télé nicolas nombre
y est allé les rencontrer dans le
quartier du val fourré
[Musique]
les arts doses dans la saison 2 de
valider série disponible sur la
plateforme mike annales les ados ce sont
les jumeaux du rap français deux jeunes
de 21 ans originaire de mantes la jolie
ils ont déjà plusieurs titres à leur
actif
[Musique]
l'équipe a fait pour les faire danser tu
connais pas les six mois du rapport
[Musique]
ryanair a où vivent dans le quartier du
val fourré à gutenberg dans leur musique
ils racontent leur quotidien en 2018 il
signe avec le label wati b cette
signature leur tremplin pour aller
chercher plus haut à mon avis personne
dans l'excès nous quand on veut quelque
chose on se dit pas je vais tout faire
pour avoir ces je vais la voir je vais
l'avoir dont vous nous voit tibet on a
eu cette idée mais on sait pas quoi
tibet on veut aussi dire si on veut
devenir des meilleurs les argos font
leurs débuts ici dans le centre culturel
des ateliers chopin à mantes la jolie à
l'âge de 13 ans ils viennent lancer leur
premier flot et prennent des cours avec
mr mam professeur de musique au sein de
la structure c'est une fierté ou moins
franchement change pas brogard
à leur égard et on a toujours la même
relation même malgré qu'ils soient voilà
qui disait de la notoriété qui font des
choses très intéressantes moi c'est une
fierté déjà que les jeunes qui sont
sortis d'ici puissent faire ce genre de
choses fan de musique les arts d'eau
sont plusieurs influences il écoute de
tout mais le rap américain et français
est dominant même si la musique reste la
priorité ils ont une activité
professionnelle en parallèle ça nous
ouvre plus l'esprit on aura plus de
choses à raconter dans nos musiques etc
mais il faut savoir que on a toujours la
même détermination pour la musique dans
l'opulence et on est encore en
développement c'est encore du charbon on
travaille on travaille en studio on
enchaîne les clips on enchaîne des
projets des mixtapes pourquoi pas
l'album ce premier album devrait
s'intituler les jumeaux du rap français
en attendant une série de freestyle est
en cours de production un clin d'oeil à
leur apparition dans la série validé
[Musique]
avant de vous quitter lé la fière
représentante de la jeunesse du
sud-yvelines la reine du muguet sera élu
fin janvier à rambouillet si vous
souhaitez succéder à mme eliane du pirée
l'ue en 2020 vous pouvez candidate et
jusqu'au 5 novembre seule condition
avoir entre 17 et 25 ans les
inscriptions peuvent se faire par
téléphone ou via le mail qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran et lui n'est pas le
roi du muguet mais il pourrait être
désigné à coup sûr roi de la réalisation
est la fin de ce journal est pour moi
l'occasion de saluer un roman russe pini
qui s'en va à voguer vers de nouvelles
aventures quatre années de collaboration
pour ma part à ses côtés et lui à la
réalisation elle était aux manettes en
coulisses pour permettre est bien la
bonne tenue de ce journal bravo romain
merci et bon vent voilà c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de votre fidélité
demain vendredi on vous donne rendez
vous avec le 7-8 week-end bixente
mayence insisté ban et moi même on vous
a compté concocté un petit programme
autour d'halloween belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]